hi my name is Dan Kohler and I'm from
elon university my documentary film when
her lose tells a story photographer
Curtis Brown and his campaign against a
proposed constitutional amendment
banning same-sex marriage in North
Carolina I hope you enjoy the clip on my
eighth when the polls close I want to
hear the cheers on the streets I want to
feel the chills in your body because you
know that North Carolina is protected
it's that kind of feeling that that I'm
hoping for but I'm afraid that's not
going to happen it's one sentence
steeped in controversy voters are asked
to choose for or against the survey from
public policy polling shows fifty-eight
percent are in favor of the amendment to
know the numbers a small part of me
feels defeated but we're going to keep
fighting
how are you man you excited get your
photo taken keep show me your smile
awesome all right I can't be in it with
you all right big family hug awesome
it's a crazy line
just never ends I can't even see the end
of it it's our first time in durham so
for me I'm gonna look back and know we
started a huge bang and we're ending
with a bigger explosion like this is the
best way to go out awesome thank you so
much I mean look at this there's so many
people so I don't know the time it is I
don't know where we are I don't even
know who I am but the show must go on
Oh
I just want to say thank you because it
means so much to see something that's
just an idea and I dream in my head turn
into 5,000 people I mean it's incredible
it's a big fight ahead let's break down
and have a beer so I need like 10